[MUSIC PLAYING]
SUBJECT 1: Tonight I'm headed to
a dinner party in downtown San
Francisco.
It's going to be a very
intimate affair, outdoors
with 16 people in a dumpster.
This should be interesting.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SUBJECT 1: Our host
for the evening
is Josh Treuhaft, who
designed these events as part
of his master's thesis, to
try to start a conversation
about food waste.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOSH TREUHAFT: The
Salvage Supper Club
is about inspiring
and empowering people
to make the most of the
edible food in their lives.
There's untapped
potential in their food
that for some reason,
not to their own fault,
is going to waste.
What we do is host multi-course
dining experiences,
where every course is made out
of food that would commonly
go to waste.
It's prepared by chefs who
really know what they're doing.
And it's food that people could
make on their own, oftentimes.
SUBJECT 1: Proceeds from
these dinner parties
go to organizations that
are feeding people in need
with food that would have
otherwise gone to waste.
JOSH TREUHAFT: It
seems strange to me
that we have people
who can't always
put a square meal
on their table,
and we're throwing away
40% of our food supply.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOSH TREUHAFT: About
62.5 million tons of food
is wasted annually in the
U.S. About 16% of that
is at the farm, so
that's food that doesn't
pass cosmetic standards.
And then the other 84% is food
waste that's going to landfill.
So that's in the food supply.
It's been harvested,
but then somewhere,
either at the consumer's
home, at a restaurant,
at a grocery store, have food
that's not getting eaten.
SUBJECT 1: What is ugly food?
JOSH TREUHAFT: It
doesn't look the way
the retailer or the
distributor or the consumer
needs or wants it
to, and so it's not
worth investing the time
to harvest it and put it
into the food supply.
Because they don't think
somebody's going to buy it.
There's a spectrum that
exists, which I call
the spectrum of desirability.
At one end of that spectrum
is the perfect shiny apples.
And at the other
end of that spectrum
is something that
you and I would not
consider to be edible.
And most people tend to focus
and eat at the very front end.
But in reality, the majority
of that spectrum is edible.
SUBJECT 1: To prepare
for tonight's event,
Chef Pesha Perlsweig
visited various markets
to see what ingredients she
could transform into a six
course dinner.
JOSH TREUHAFT: She
finds ingredients
that are going to go
to waste, and then she
turns it into these intricate,
amazing, interesting dishes
that people love.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SUBJECT 1: This is
Imperfect Produce.
It's a business that
specializes in selling
imperfect, or ugly fruits and
vegetables that might otherwise
be thrown away.
PESHA PERLSWEIG: So it's
things like sweet potatoes
that might have been
a little bit broken.
Maybe the pluot or the
plum is a little too small.
And I'm trying to
take those ingredients
and turn it into something
palatable and really wonderful.
This kale, for instance--
this one at the top
actually looks kind of pretty.
But if you go down, you'll see
that there's some yellowing,
there's some spotting, and
it's really going limp.
And we'll probably pickle them
in a little bit of this citrus.
And I'm going to make
a roll out of It.
We're about to serve
the next course, which
is wilted kale rolls.
They are stuffed with sweet
potatoes and chickpeas, as well
as a romesco sauce,
but instead of tomatoes
I decided to use stone fruit.
In front of you, you
have a ratatouille
that has been comprised out of
summer squash from our friends
at Surplus.
And tomatoes from our
friends at Imperfect.
And eggplant from our
friends at Buyrite.
It has been cooked down with
garlic and spent red wine.
You have a banana doughnut.
Then you have three different
types of ice creams.
One actually is a sorbet,
it's a pineapple sorbet.
SUBJECT 2: That one's delicious.
PESHA PERLSWEIG: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SUBJECT 1: Trying all of
this delicious food made
from what the industry considers
trash really blew me away.
It made me think about how
much food waste I produce,
and our society's obsession
with cosmetic perfection.
Do you think that
this experience
has inspired you to think
differently about your own food
consumption and waste?
SUBJECT 3: Absolutely.
Most definitely.
Before this evening, I think,
just like creature of habit,
so maybe it doesn't look good,
then throw it away, toss it
away.
But after tonight, and
seeing what chefs can do,
or just home cooks can do.
A great experience.
JOSH TREUHAFT: Just
think for one minute
when you have
something, is there
a reason that I don't eat this,
or do I just throw it away
because I've always
thrown it away?
Somewhere around $218 billion
is the economic impact
of that food.
It's a lot of money's worth of
food that is not getting eaten,
that we are investing in
growing and transporting
and distributing.
And that is ending
up in a landfill.
There are huge consequences
to the current system.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SUBJECT 1: What do you hope for
the future of this movement,
or the issue of food waste?
JOSH TREUHAFT: A
food system where
we don't have people
who are struggling
to get a square meal.
That's an aspiration that we
should constantly fight for,
because everybody needs to eat.
My hope is that in my lifetime,
I will see that that changes.
SUBJECT 1: Check out
this next episode
to see how this
major U.S. City is
striving to become zero waste.
SUBJECT 4: When I started
at Recology 23 years ago,
the recycling rate
was around 38%.
Today we've more
than doubled that.
SUBJECT 1: So far San Francisco
has diverted 80% of its waste
away from landfills.
And its success has been
getting global attention.
Thanks for watching, and be sure
to subscribe for more Seeker
Stories.